for over a month the left has insisted
we lock down our country towns cities
even whole states have ordered citizens
to stay locked in their homes but now
that President Trump is applying that
logic to the national level by locking
down our borders the left is up in arms
foreign nationals can hop our fences and
enter the country by the millions but
you can't take a simple walk around the
neighborhood
doesn't seem very fair then CNN's Chris
Cuomo stages some broadway-caliber fake
news before getting caught in the
obvious lie
New York's mayor de Blasio calls for a
ticker-tape pandemic parade probably not
the smartest thing and an earth day
co-founder murders his girlfriend all
that and more I'm Michael Knowles and
this is the Michael Nolt show
[Music]
once again it's all about immigration
President Trump when he walked down that
escalator in 2015 and announced he was
running for president he made
immigration the issue of his campaign
that was considered controversial at the
time the other Republican candidates
didn't really want to touch it
Trump totally embraced the issue and
guess what that issue propelled him to
win the Republican nomination despite
what you heard in the mainstream media
despite what you heard from
establishment Republicans there was
broad consensus among Americans that we
had to stop illegal immigration that we
had to reduce legal immigration this was
backed up in public opinion poll after
public opinion poll now we're locking
down the whole country right you're not
allowed to leave your home not only are
you not allowed to go to bars and
restaurants if you leave your home to go
on a walk around the neighborhood
there's a chance that you will be
harassed by a cop
that's how certain we are that we need
to lock this down
that's how certain we are that walls
work and yet when you try to apply this
logic to the national level the left
goes crazy they're furious they say no
forget about the virus forget and listen
the virus is only something American
citizens have to worry about we should
continue to flood the country with
immigration that doesn't make a lot of
sense it's a it's a double standard so
President Trump is going hard once again
after the immigration issue he is going
to halt all immigration virtually all
immigration to the United States for 60
days for two specific reasons in this
pandemic here's President Trump in order
to protect American workers I will be
issuing a temporary suspension of
immigration into the United States you
heard about that last night by pausing
immigration will help put unemployed
Americans first in line for jobs as
America reopens so important it would be
wrong and unjust for Americans laid off
by the virus to be replaced with new
immigrant labor flown in from abroad
we must first take care of the American
worker take care of the American worker
this pause will be in effect for 60 days
after which the need for any extension
or modification will be evaluated by
myself and a group of people based on
economic conditions at the time this
pause our new immigration will also help
to conserve vital medical resources for
American citizens a short break from new
immigration depending on the time we're
talking about will protect the solvency
of our health care system and provide
relief to jobless Americans now listen
to the way he frames this this is so
smart it you would think that the way to
frame the immigration issue during a
pandemic is to make it a question of
Public Health obviously right if I'm not
allowed I'm a New Yorker I live in
California right now I'm not allowed to
go to New York
because people are afraid of spreading
the virus so if we've got to reduce even
the travel among American citizens to
other states certainly we should be
reducing the travel of people from
different countries that are affected by
the virus in to the United States right
certainly travel from China maybe Italy
maybe anywhere all over the place but he
doesn't frame it as a public health
issue he frames it as an economic issue
and the reason for that is one this is
primarily an economic issue you've got
22 million Americans who lost their jobs
over the last four weeks who knows how
many over the past week we still don't
have those numbers yet and so with
unemployment now approaching 20% surely
you should not be flooding the country
with millions of immigrants per year and
that's that's always been kind of at the
bottom of the of the immigration issue
for the majority of Americans there are
cultural aspects as well sure but for I
think for most people what it comes down
to is an economic issue when you fled
the country with immigrants then all of
a sudden you've got much more
competition for certain jobs and the
wages decrease he makes it an economic
issue also because then it's very
clearly not a racial issue right that
what the left always says and they did
it this time again as always this is
xenophobia it's racist it's bigoted no
it's economic he's saying no I'm not I
don't care I'm not even complaining
about what language they speak I they
look how they dress what you know what
their names are that's not the problem
the problem is a simple economic fact
when you've got 22 million Americans who
lose their jobs in a month
you shouldn't flood the country with
foreigners who are going to compete for
their jobs once the economy reopens very
simple not Senna phobic of course that
did not stop the mainstream media from
smearing Trump as a racist but there is
a number coming out of public opinion
polling that should make the media and
the left very wary of using that race
baiting tactic we'll get to it in a
second first I've got to thank our
friends over at Nets week you know now
more than ever with this level of
economic uncertainty businesses need
systems that give them complete
visibility into their numbers
NetSuite by Oracle the world's number
one cloud business system NetSuite gives
you the financials cash flow payroll
inventory and more all in one place so
that you have clear visibility and total
control of your business
NetSuite customers have the flexibility
to work from anywhere with immediate
clarity on critical information right at
their fingertips very helpful these days
no more guessing no more waiting make
smarter decisions with confidence
okay join over 20,000 companies who
trust NetSuite to stay in control it
would be a big mistake
to blindly stumble through the crisis
that we're in right now okay so check
out NetSuite it will give business
owners the tools they need right now
receive your free guide managing
business uncertainty and schedule your
free product or right now NetSuite comm
slash Knowles don't wait to get your
free guide and schedule your free
product or NetSuite comm slash Knowles
NetSuite com slash canna wles
Trump could not have been more crystal
clear about this issue it's an economic
issue
so naturally the media screams racism
since the outbreak the White House has
been using the virus to just a
I increased restrictions on immigration
they've basically been working up to
this a move like this though would be
absolutely unprecedented and would
essentially shut down the legal
immigration system and one thing is
certain this is definitely going to be
challenged in court
opponents are calling this xenophobic
this morning the president's hardline
immigration supporters they are praising
the move but opponents are calling it
zena phobic okay basically nothing that
she's saying on the issue itself is
accurate here
or even or even journalism because look
the way that she frames it always
opponents are calling a xenophobic who
are the opponents what are their names
are their names
ABC News because I think those are the
opponents you just don't want to admit
that you opposed it because it makes you
look like a hack so the only people who
support it are hardline immigration
hawks really probably racists am i right
and the people who oppose it their
opponents and they're calling it
xenophobic okay now look I'm just
reporting the news that's what they call
it now me and then those hardline maniac
Klansmen over there they're the ones who
support this well public polling shows
that that's not right it's actually the
opposite but then the way she even
frames the issue the whole issue is
Trump has been building up to this oh he
was so happy when that pandemic came
around oh he couldn't be more happy
about coronavirus because it gives him a
chance to shut down immigration which is
so unfair and wrong and illogical no
it's not it's perfectly logical he's
saying everybody's got is shut down
except the immigrants the immigrants get
to flood the country by two million a
year I don't think so so they're they're
pushing this xenophobia narrative not
just her though you're getting even
actually more from ABC on the bigotry on
the racism on the xenophobia there were
strict orders there are strict orders
already in place but even a temporary
pause would be unprecedented in this
country look here's what we know there
will be some exceptions exceptions
exemptions rather for health care
workers agricultural workers people like
that but you heard the president say
this is about protecting American jobs
he also says this is about protecting
Americans from the coronavirus but David
we've got to tell you America has more
confirmed coronavirus
cases than anywhere else in the world we
should also note that the number of
immigrants who were on the frontlines in
this fight right now one in four Dockers
one in three nurses our immigrants david
opponents say that this is a clear
example of the president using this
virus to further his hardline
immigration policies this one sure to
end up in the courts David
that's what opponents say hi that's my
report
I am opponent virtually nothing that she
just said here is true she says it would
be unprecedented to drastically reduce
immigration we've done that multiple
times in this country most notably in
1924 we more or less shut down the
immigration system and that persisted
for decades until Teddy Kennedy reopened
the whole thing and transformed the
country and I hope to try to get some
more votes for the Democratic Party it's
happened before that as well so not
unprecedented then she says that he's
using the coronavirus public health
scare as the basis for the immigration
room it just is not true you heard what
he said it's an economic question he's
not making it a question of public
health and then the opponents say sure
the opponents do say it at ABC News not
just ABC News though NBC News was
getting in on it as well
it's still unclear when he'll sign it
but even without an executive order
immigration during the coronavirus
crisis has already slowed dramatically
with the administration imposing broad
travel restrictions and suspending
immigrant visas critics say the order is
a political dog whistle aimed at
energizing the president's base yeah
that's what the critics say and the
opponents say and/or the critics and
opponents ABC or the NBC I guess they're
NBC it's a dog whistle what is a dog
whistle a dog what he's saying is it's
racist right dog whistle is used almost
exclusively in the context of racism you
notice how it's only the left that ever
hears this dog whistle the right never
seems to hear it guess that would make
the left the dogs doesn't it if you're
the only one who hears the dog whistle I
believe that makes you the dogs
there's nothing dog whistle e about this
first of all it's obviously not a dog
whistle B as president Trump has been
campaigning on this since the first day
of his presidential political career
immigration has been the issue as it
should be Republicans don't get this
conservatives don't get this because
they believe the left-wing narrative
immigration is a winning issue cutting
immigration I mean not encouraging it
encouraging more immigration is a losing
issue among huge swaths of the American
public
Harvard Harris poll just came out a
total of eighty three percent more than
five foot five and six people or so say
that they favor a moratorium on
immigration through the southwest border
amid the pandemic not reduce it a little
bit not reduce it a lot stop it
completely eighty-three percent of all
Americans not just Republicans not just
from supporters that figure includes
three-quarters of Mexican Americans very
difficult for this to be a racist order
if the race that it's allegedly
discriminating against overwhelmingly
supports the order 75% of Mexican
Americans think we should completely
shut down the border during the pandemic
and then ninety three percent of
Republican voters think we should
completely shut down the border amid the
pandemic I remember there was a poll
that came out think now is a year and a
half two years ago among democratic
moderate independent voters the majority
of them supported reducing not just
illegal immigration but legal
immigration and not just a little bit
but a lot reducing it by something like
sixty percent okay this is just common
sense we now have the highest
foreign-born percentage of the
population that we've had in well over a
hundred years this creates problems in
any sort of country but particularly in
ours which does not have a particularly
racial identity right they're a whole
lot of people in this country does not
have a particularly long history we're a
relatively young country so assimilation
is very important and you've got the
left discouraging assimilation
encouraging people not to assimilate to
the United States so of course if you
flood it with immigrants that's going to
be much more difficult you know politics
is circumstantial and contextual you
have to deal with with new and changing
circumstances right now when you've got
a ton of immigrants in the country
and not a lot of assimilation that would
be the time to reduce it whether there's
a pandemic or not and the vast majority
of Americans agree on this issue but
Republicans don't learn that because
they don't want to be called racists it
it is obviously not a racist issue ask
the three quarters of Mexican Americans
who support the order what people are
not getting is that immigration matters
because it is an existential issue in a
democracy in a dictatorship it doesn't
really matter right because you're gonna
get the same policies regardless of who
comes in and out of the country in a
monarchy and an oligarchy sure in a
democracy
immigration will directly affect the
kind of governance you get the kind of
country you have immediately when the
people decide how the government is run
then it really really matters how the
people are made up this is obviously not
a matter of racial solidarity there is
incredible solidarity generally on this
issue among all different races all
different kind of people all different
political ideologies there's some rumor
coming out right now that the certain
advisors in the White House are
encouraging Trump to back off of this
executive order they're out of their
minds they're insane Trump should have
done this years ago okay because even
when we talk about a moratorium on
immigration he's not saying a total stop
all immigration that would be crazy
there are always exigencies they're
always cases where you know someone
needs to come into the country where
would be unfair to shut it down
completely but it should be drastically
reduced this is not even a new idea on
the right
you know I remember on firing line on
William F Buckley his program in the
1990s they were debating whether or not
to drastically reduce legal immigration
not just illegal but legal immigration
and I think you had Arianna Huffington
in the affirmative saying that we should
reduce legal immigration that was back
when she was more conservative still
this was a totally open topic
for a debate among the totally most
mainstream conservatives ever this is
not some fringe idea it's not some new
idea there's a long-standing history in
the United States and Trump should do
this quickly Joe Biden of course already
opportunistically trying to flip on this
issue
unfortunately Joe's not particularly
sprightly these days so his a new attack
on Trump is falling very flat it
highlights just about everything that is
wrong with the Biden campaign in the
state of the left right now a lot of
hypocrisy not just on that issue but
even on the reopening of various states
we'll get to that in a second first I
got to thank our pals the Benham
brothers you know I've been around la
long enough to have seen a lot of
get-rich-quick schemes a lot of people
have told me this is how they're gonna
totally change their life overnight and
you know they're gonna get really really
rich and you know they've reached
they're gonna reach the top of success
and they're miserable so what's the
secret to building a business the truth
is you can grow a business without
sacrificing your family and character
might not be a get rich quick overnight
kind of thing that's not going to happen
but you can grow your business and you
can't keep your character that brings me
to the Benham brothers all right they've
got over a dozen businesses including a
real estate empire that spans over 35
states and they didn't sell their soul
for it and it wasn't just some kind of
crazy fluke on overnight right they
built it strongly over time and they
kept their character you might remember
the Benham brothers they were slated for
a reality TV show on HGTV and they were
cancelled because of their commitment to
conservative values so-called business
coaches tell you that your life has to
take a backseat to your hustle not David
and Jason Bentham or proof that that is
a lie just this week the Bentham
Brothers launched their new course
expert ownership it's the model they've
used to build each one of their
businesses and whether you're sick of
the 9 to 5 or you have a 10 year old
business expert ownership can help you
to achieve your goals right now they're
offering 15% off to new members check
out a preview of that course and take
advantage of that discount over at
Benton brothers comm / Knowles
that's benh am brothers comm / knowles
head on over check out the course Joe
Biden
is now trying to take advantage of this
situation
you remember initially when when Trump
shut down travel from China Biden called
it xenophobic he criticized him for it
but now I guess Biden Singh the same
poll numbers on this immigration issue
that all the rest of us are and so he's
now criticizing Trump for not shutting
down travel fast enough for not being
hard enough on China here is Joe Biden's
implausible attack ad he failed to act
so now Trump and his allies are
launching negative attacks against Joe
Biden to hide the truth here are the
facts Joe Biden warned the nation in
January the Trump had left us unprepared
for a pandemic then Biden told Trump he
should insist on having American health
experts on the ground in China I would
be on the phone with China and making it
clear we are going to need to be in your
country you have to be open you have to
be clear we have to know what's going on
but Trump rolled over through the
Chinese he took their word for president
tweeted China has been working very hard
to contain the coronavirus the United
States greatly appreciates their efforts
and transparency China I spoke with
President Xi and they're working very
very hard and I think it's gonna all
work out fine Trump praised the Chinese
15 times
January and February as the coronavirus
spread across the world it's a tough
situation I think they're doing a very
good job all the negative ads in the
world can't change the truth
so I've got a couple of observations
here first this is ridiculous
Donald Trump is famously tough on the
Chinese Joe Biden very publicly
criticized him for being so tough on the
Chinese including recently including at
the beginning of this pandemic where he
said now is not the time for trumps
terrible awful xenophobia coronavirus
emanated from China a national emergency
and you know worldwide alerts the
American people need to have a president
who they can trust what he says about it
that he is going to act rationally about
it and moments like this this is where
credibly a president is most needed as
he explains what we should and should
not do this is no time for Donald
Trump's record of hysteria xenophobia
hysterical xenophobia so Biden's ad is
just not credible on this point right we
have the video it happened very recently
but worse than that
my actual takeaway from that ad is just
how outdated it is did you hear that the
voice Donald Trump says he's tough on
China but really he's not Donald Trump
bad on China bad for America I'm Joe
Biden and this is the 1980s like it just
sounds so old it's just that's not how
political ads are done anymore that's
how political ads were done when I was a
child when Joe Biden was only 85 it's
just he just hasn't kept up and that's
fine I mean it's not like Joe Biden is
sitting there in the Edit Bay putting
the script together but obviously his
consultants are doing that what
consultants did he hire did he like hire
the guys from the Mondale campaign or
something did he be picked up yeah
listen
Truman's consultants are free now maybe
we'll hire them for the campaign it's
just it's old and it it underscores
every problem the Biden campaign already
has what does he accomplish here does he
convince people of the point he's making
the Trump is easy angina no nobody
thinks that
is too easy on China nobody thinks that
Biden is tougher on China than Trump so
Biden hasn't won over any independent
voters or fence sitting voters right
however Biden has irritated the left
which is now accusing him of xenophobia
for his ad they're saying hey don't be
so tough on China Joe that's racist
that's bigoted that xenophobic so he
hasn't won over any new voters he hasn't
encouraged his own voters if anything he
maybe has lost some who were who were
too liberal and who are already
skeptical of Joe Biden and then worst of
all he's confirmed everybody's fears
that he's just past his sell-by date
because he's campaigning like it's 1992
instead of 2020 compare that ad that
Biden just put out to the ad the
president Trump released just two days
ago about Joe Biden the kid used to come
up reaching pull and rub my leg down so
it was training that watch the hair come
back up again they look at so I learned
about roaches I learned about kids
jumping on my lap and I love kids
[Music]
it's like these ads came from two
different centuries because really they
did the Joe Biden ad is a 20th century
political ad very direct very ominous
pretty hacky not particularly credible
with the serious deep voice man on it
and the Trump ad is a 21st century ad
it's funny it comes in it it comes at
the attack from a an interesting angle
right it's not just Joe Biden's really
old Joe Biden old for the campaign trail
old for America it's not it's not that
direct ad it's memeing it's making its
kind of using another TV commercial
that's prominent in pop culture and then
putting faces on it like a kind of weird
way like it looks like it was thrown
together in in two hours and then using
the old commercial to look like they're
making fun of Barack Obama for endorsing
Joe Biden Joe Biden who is actually the
target of the commercial
he's secondary to the whole thing that's
how interesting it is
that's how compelling it is that's how
much it pulls you in and it's
high-energy it's not bum bum Donald
Trump is bad and a liar it's DJ cool
it's like rap music hip hop at the end
right jump jump really sad and I think
indicative of the two campaigns cuz Joe
Biden was supposed to stay at home for
the pandemic get a refresher recharges
batteries hit the campaign trail again
next month and that hasn't happened he's
gotten even more exhausted apparently
whereas President Trump all energy all
the time every single day in front of
the press
you know it's evidenced that when you
work more you work more right Joe
Biden's been out of national politics
now for four years and he looks like it
he's just not up to speed where is
Donald Trump every single day he seems
to get more energy now regardless of the
production quality of these two
campaigns it is amazing that Joe Biden
can air that ad and no one in the
mainstream media will call him out for
it right he can completely flip his
possess
no one will care there is this hypocrisy
right this incredible hypocrisy and the
whole issue the left says walls work in
your home and they want to lock you
behind those walls for 18 months but
they say walls don't work at a national
level and we got to flood the country
with illegal aliens you're seeing the
same thing on jails right they're saying
we got to let all the criminals out of
jails so that they don't get coronavirus
but if you have the audacity to go to
drive-thru church we're going to arrest
you if you go for a walk in the
neighborhood we're going to arrest you
it's just exactly backwards it's just
this perfect hypocrisy you're even
seeing this not just on the pandemic
itself but on the way that states are
reopening when conservative states
reopen the left loses its mind and
they've got blood on their hands when a
liberal state reopens it's a wonderful
measured rational policy we'll get to
that in one second then we'll get to
Mayor bolshevik out of New York who is
he is reaching levels of stupidity that
you wouldn't have thought possible
speaking of which we've got AOC and then
we've got to touch on Earth Day it's
Earth Day did you forget that so did
everybody else but first I've got to
remind you that we have got a daily wire
backstage tonight it's happening the
lockdown can't keep us down we're gonna
be there smoke and stogies exercising
our lungs so that we make sure that
we're nice and healthy you should come
check it out if you are not a member
already oh boy you thought you were just
gonna get this one leftist tears tumblr
right that would be helpful that would
be good these days because the left is
falling apart Joe Biden Chris Cuomo guy
caught in a big live we'll get to that
you don't just get one you get wait for
it wait for it you get two you get two
left is tears Tumblr's that is
mathematically I'm no genius that's
twice as good become an Insider plus or
all-access member double your tears with
two left is tears tempers go to daily
wire.com slash subscribe get started get
10% off with coupon code Knowles daily
wire.com slash subscribed coupon code
Knowles get the rarest of all beverage
Baz bezels times two we'll be right back
a tale of two states and the mainstream
media two states are reopening if they
actually some more states the matter
reopening but two I think are really
indicative Georgia and Colorado Georgia
is a conservative state with a
Republican governor Colorado
increasingly a liberal state with a
Democratic governor
they are both reopening okay how do you
think the media are covering them
probably exactly the same and totally
fairly right uh maybe not George
reopening if you just type this into
Google News Georgia reopening Georgia
governor defends plan to reopen gyms
nail salons he's got to defend it
because it's it's obviously crazy it's
obviously worth worthy of being attacked
New York Times Georgia Tennessee and
South Carolina moved to reopen as hot
spots emerge like that why the hell are
they reopening the hot spots are
emerging that's what the media told me
Lindsey Graham warns that Georgia is
opening too soon amid coronavirus
Newsweek Georgia governor Kemp defends
reopening of state New York Times
I am beyond disturbed internal dissent
as states reopen despite virus that
shows up right on the first page of the
Georgia results Washington Post thirteen
hours ago
Georgia leads the race to become an
America's number one death destination
okay CNN Georgia Governor Brian Kemp
faces resistance over move to reopen the
economy TMZ Atlanta's celebrity hair
stylists and makeup artists not cool
with Georgia reopening well if the hair
stylists are not cool with it I guess we
got to stay shut down you know it's
funny too the last time that the
mainstream media was attacking Georgia
it was attacking Georgia because it
would not allow people to kill their
babies in Georgia remember so they
actually certain liberal institutions
universities they wouldn't allow you to
travel to Georgia because it was
insistent that you not kill your baby
there but now they're accusing it of
being America's number one death death
destination last time you're accusing it
for not being enough of a death
destination so that's Georgia
how about Colorado
which is doing the same thing how
Colorado will slowly reopen from its
coronavirus stay at home work oh slowly
sounds measured governor Poulos outlines
initial plan for lifting some
restrictions allowing certain businesses
to reopen wow it makes total sense
Colorado moving to safer at home status
that sounds like it sees taking it even
more seriously now a safer at home
status is a code word for reopening but
it's different than then stay at home
status like you have to state home this
is safer at home so you'd be better to
stay but you can go out with Colorado's
stay at home order successful Poulos
outlines plans to reopen it was so
successful that now we're good because
we beat coronavirus forget about all
those hot spots it reemerging it's okay
it's successful we're good Denver Post
Colorado to shift from stay-at-home to
safer at home as some businesses can
begin reopening this week I mean on and
on and on this is what you can expect
for the next melt but for the next
forever but certainly during this
pandemic
whenever Republicans do anything it will
be bad and they will have blood on their
hands whenever Democrats do the exact
same thing it will be wonderful and
successful and saving lives
you've got to tune out the news on this
the new it's not the news you've got to
turn to now the mainstream media on this
they are at this point just lying to you
CNN's Chris Cuomo is actually lying to
you we have proof positive of it and
it's a it's a hypocrisy of the sort
you've never seen anything like it first
we got to check in though on North Korea
you remember how Kim jong-un was
apparently gravely ill possibly brain
dead possibly just dead altogether well
we still don't know no one's seen him
for a long time Brett Baier of Fox News
one of the last good journalists left in
America asked President Trump this
question yesterday at the press briefing
North Korea what do you what can you
tell us about the status Kim Jong well
these are reports that came out and we
don't know we don't know I've had a very
good relationship with them I would
you know I can only say this I wish him
well because if he is in the kind of
condition that the reports say that the
news is saying there'll be a that's a
very serious condition as you know but I
wish him well then we've had a good
relationship I've said it and I've said
it many times if somebody else were in
this position we would have been right
now at war with North Korea and we're
not at war we're nowhere close to war
with North Korea so I just have to say
to Kim jong-un I wish him very you know
good luck good luck I mean they came out
with very very serious medical reports
nobody's confirmed that it's was C and
then that came out so when CNN comes out
with the report
I don't place too much credence in it
like the blind at the end I mean the
North Korea update there is no update we
don't know where the guy is we don't
know if he's alive or dead or not
I just love that bit at the end look the
reports from CNN if CNN comes out with
it take it with a grain of salt and he's
right that he's not just right on it as
a general point CNN just got caught in a
lie that would have made Joseph Stalin
blush in propaganda that would have made
the most hardened leftist cynical liars
blush and it was CNN using one of their
main anchors to do it Chris Cuomo whose
brother is Andrew Cuomo the governor of
New York maybe the most prominent
governor in the whole corona virus
epidemic I've actually got to get
through three New York stooges right in
a row one more ridiculous than the next
Chris Cuomo got coronavirus and he kept
doing his show so obviously it wasn't
that bad and he was hunkering down in
his basement so he said and now after
weeks and weeks in isolation didn't see
his kids didn't see his wife didn't see
anybody probably just getting gruel and
slop put through like a common prisoner
he was able to re-emerge from his
basement and he filmed the whole thing
but something just seemed off it seemed
a little bit artificial all right here
is the official
range from the basement cleared by CDC
little sway just worked out happens this
is what I've been dreaming of literally
for weeks
my wife she was cleared by the CDC she
doesn't have fevers and other symptoms
anymore more than seven days from her
quarantine I'm still a little scared so
I'll just give you one of these just
give you one of these just give you one
of these just give you one of these
Bella has of course taking the video
this is the dream just to be back up
here doing normal things did anything
about that seem normal to you did
anything about that seem credible at all
no it's weird right like he didn't he
hasn't seen his wife and kids and weeks
and that's how he says hello to them he
hasn't been out of the basement ever not
once at all not even after they went to
bed that doesn't seem very credible he
would film this moment it's just it's
just weird right also Chris Cuomo is a
journalist he's supposed to cover
stories right he's not supposed to be
the story and yet he's making this whole
segment about him what's this all about
well it turns out that whole segment
that you just saw is a lie it's a lie
because Chris Cuomo has already left his
basement probably multiple times we know
he's left his basement because a week
ago he was caught outside standing very
close with his family by somebody who
was on a bicycle who he ended up getting
into an altercation with and they had
words and they argued and and we know
that he violated the order that his own
brother instituted so on Easter Sunday
65 year old East Hampton man was at
riding his bike and saw Cuomo outside
with his wife and another woman and
three kids so one of the women
approached this guy whose name is David
according to the New York Post and said
may I help you and David said he asked
Cuomo
why Cuomo was not social distancing like
he had been talking about doing on his
own CNN show and like his brother
mandated everybody in New York do and
how do you think Cuomo responded you
remember the last time somebody
approached
quoi Mon called him Fredo and a bar in
New York Cuomo just starts screaming at
him gets in his face threatens to beat
him up so Cuomo typical Fredo fashion
goes out there and reportedly says quote
who the hell are you I can do what I
want and apparently just ranted and he
was screaming sand I'll find out who you
are and David the 65 year old man the
senior citizen says your brother's the
coronavirus are and you're not even
following his rules unnecessary travel
and apparently that by the way this guy
David's barely a Democrat who voted for
Cuomo and David says he just began to
boil more he said this is not the end of
this you'll deal with this later we will
meet again if that's not a threat I
don't know what is okay so maybe David's
just making this up right could be maybe
David's just not telling the truth
except a week ago Chris Cuomo himself
admitted that this happened he talked
about the altercation and he was
apparently even more angry then than he
was in person and I don't want some JAC
loser fat tire biker to be able to pull
over and get him my face and in my space
and talk both to me I don't want to hear
it that's what this is all about do you
remember a week ago this was a weird
news story I didn't even cover it on
this show cuz I don't really care that
much about Chris Cuomo there was this
headline Chris Cuomo did a radio
interview and he said he's upset about
what he's doing and he doesn't like his
job and he he wants to quit he doesn't
like being the public eye and then he
kind of walked it back the next day and
so what what was that I was so weird
apparently this whole stunt this walking
out of the basement for the first time
it's all just to cover up this fact that
Chris Cuomo was not abiding by the
quarantine order or the social
distancing he was not listening even to
his own brother who's the governor of
New York and then he was going on CNN
and lying about it to you and making
himself the story and he continues to
lie about it today the people pushing
the lockdowns don't believe in them okay
I have now been saying and I've been
saying it for weeks that this doesn't
seem very credible because what one all
the models turned out to be incorrect
and overblown as we said they very
likely would be there's no evidence that
the lockdowns are doing anything at all
that they're saving
any lives okay we're told that the lock
downs are to flatten the curve I think
people don't know what flatten the curve
means flatten the curve does not mean
save lives necessarily flatten the curve
means reduce the peak number of cases to
below the hospital capacity right
because if you go above the hospital
capacity then people could die because
there are just aren't enough beds there
aren't enough doctors if you push it
below the hospital capacity you're good
now people are still gonna die but
there's no way to control at that point
there's no way to reduce how many people
will die because flattening the curve
doesn't reduce the number of infections
doesn't reduce the number of people
absent and and hospital over
overwhelming that will die from the
coronavirus it just spreads it out it
just makes it last a little bit longer
the only way that flattening the curve
could reduce the number of deaths is if
the hospitals are overrun which isn't
happening anywhere including in New York
or if we can get a vaccine quickly which
we can't we don't have a vaccine and the
experts are saying it's going to take 18
months but the virus is already
spreading so fast that won't matter the
people who are gonna get it are going to
get it before the vaccine comes out so
the lockdowns are not saving any lives
if those things are true which they
appear to be however we know the
lockdowns are costing people's lives
because the unemployment is ticking up
that increases suicides that increases
drug overdoses other issues as well
which we've talked about on this show
the people pushing the lockdowns this is
like the cherry on top of the sundae to
argue against the lock dance the people
pushing them don't believe in them
they're willing to lie about them on
television like Hippocrates likes Chris
Cuomo but even Chris Cuomo and equal
Moe's own brother doesn't believe in
them and yet they expect us to because
they're different rules there's a
different set of rules for American
citizens regular old Americans and media
people and politicians and immigrants
and everybody else other than you and
it's BS and we should push back on Bill
DeBlasio a great example mayor of New
York the second New York stooge Bill
DeBlasio is from day one violating the
lockdown orders he says everyone's got
to lock down and then he keeps going to
the gym remember the lady in Chicago
mayor of Chicago Lori Lightfoot said
everyone's going to lock down don't get
any
and then she gets a haircut different
set of rules for her so now de Blasio he
puts his foot in his mouth again
he says when we reopen the first thing
we're gonna do the first a moment that
we can can stop social distancing is
we're gonna have a ticker tape parade
and bring up millions and millions of
Americans to stand really really close
to one another here is the day is coming
when this city will fight our way back
when this city will get back to normal
the day is coming when we will overcome
this disease the day is coming when I'm
gonna be able to tell you we can gather
again the day is coming when I'll be
able to tell you in fact we will be
having the concerts and the street fairs
and the parades
again but I want to guarantee you one
thing that when that day comes that we
can restart the vibrant beautiful life
of this city again the first thing we
will do is we will have a ticker tape
parade down the canyon of heros for our
health care workers and our first
responders we will honor those who saved
us the first thing we will do before we
think about anything else is we will
take a time as only New York City can do
to throw the biggest best parade to
honor these heroes the first thing we
will do when we think we've sort of got
this highly contagious virus under
control is hold a citywide orgy we have
to hold a citywide orgy I mean young and
old men and women and everything in
between we're gonna do that that's what
New Yorkers do the moment that we we
think we've got this contagion under
control we're all just gonna rub up on
each other really really close it's kind
of too hot too cold here mayor de Blasio
how about just reopening some businesses
and getting a little bit back to normal
and still being careful and maybe don't
flood the country or the city rather
with like 12 million people in the
streets all at once okay maybe just
start with like 12 people okay or 1200
even 12,000 but you know you don't need
to go zero to 60 immediately another my
third New York stooge
Oh see just tweeted out something it was
an attack on Tucker Carlson but she a
OSE doesn't realize that two things can
be true at once so Tucker has you know
criticized her just like other people on
the right if criticized her and they've
said look she's this bartender who
doesn't know a whole lot about
legislation and the country be better
off without her and also she's lying
about her upbringing she actually is
more privileged than she says she is so
AOC is really upset about this she
tweets that am I just a bartender who
should go back to making drinks without
health insurance or am I secretly a
deceitful child of privilege because I'm
an heiress of the Swanson frozen food
Empire oh wait sorry that's Tucker
Carlson okay so she's getting this dig
in at Tucker and she's saying which is
it
am I just a bartender who should go back
to making drinks or am i a secret child
of privilege both she's both she is both
I know that she pretends like she's not
but she is she is privileged she grew up
in a very very wealthy town the town
actually coincidentally next to the town
I grew up in at exactly the same time
except her town is much wealthier very
very wealthy town in a very very wealthy
County one of the richest counties in
the country and then she attended a very
expensive private school Boston
University didn't do her much good but
I'm sure she paid a lot of money for it
that is privileged even if she got a
scholarship which I don't think she did
but even if she did right she's still
obviously is a product of this privilege
then after college she became a
bartender and the country would be
better off if she went back to mixing
drinks those things are both true she's
saying she's saying how could I be a
child of privilege if I had a modest
profession after college I don't know I
don't know why you chose the job she
chose being a bartender is perfectly
fine thing I'm friends with a lot of my
bartenders you can be both things at
once you can be a rich kid or a
privileged kid or come from a rich place
right those are different things but the
effect of it is kind of the same it's
privileged and you can be a bartender so
that's all true she realized I think the
problem here and then she doubled and
she says also can we talk
about how racist and classist the
presumption is that when people say
they're from the Bronx folks like Tucker
equate that with assuming all the worst
things about our upbringing our lives
don't have to match some chicken airs
idea of a struggle to be validated aoc
is saying that it's wrong to equate
growing up in the Bronx with a tough
upbringing she's the one doing that
that's why she's pretending that she
grew up in the Bronx is because she
wants it to seem like she had a tougher
upbringing that she actually did and by
the way she didn't grow up in the Bronx
I bet you I've spent much more time in
the Bronx than she has it's because her
only argument is well on the weekends
she would occasionally go visit family
in the Bronx yeah me too man okay we all
I will into the Bronx on the weekends
that's where you buy the good super Sun
in the prosciutto okay so it's all so
stunningly hypocritical and off note it
is possible that a OSI can have the
worst of all things she can have all of
that that unearned privilege right which
is so terrible according to the left and
she can still not know very much of
anything and be bad for the country
those two things can be true at once
before we go just want to remind you
it's Earth Day and it's the fiftieth
anniversary of Earth Day and to
commemorate this event we should remind
you that one of the Earth Day founders
is a lunatic murderer who killed and
composted his girlfriend that guy's name
is IRA Einhorn he was a master of
ceremonies at the first Earth Day
celebration in Philadelphia in 1970
April 22nd seven years after that event
his girlfriend dumped him because he was
a weird hippie loser and so he when she
came over to his house to get her stuff
he murdered her and then stuffed her in
a trunk and composted her because he did
take his environmentalism very seriously
he then like so many lifts leftists
before and after got away with his crime
for at least some time the next year
after he murdered his girlfriend Harvard
gave him a lecturing position hired him
to teach at the Institute of Politics is
they love those left wing radicals
they're right they welcomed him with
open arms you can read about it in the
Harvard Crimson newspaper finally they
caught him because there was this weird
red brown liquid that was leaking from
the
sealing of the apartment underneath his
then the co-founder of Earth Day jumped
bail fled the country for 17 years
finally was extradited and put on trial
here the left always tries to call this
fake news of the Earth Day founders and
the mainstream media they try to say
this guy IRA Einhorn had no relationship
to earth day he was not a co-founder but
the photos don't lie he he was he
portrayed himself as a co-founder at the
time and afterward history books about
it have portrayed him as a co-founder
and described him that way there were
photos from the event with all the
crowds in front of him of him speaking
at the lectern at the microphone he
obviously was very involved in the
planning of the first Earth Day and that
is an uncomfortable truth because he
like so many environmentalists was an
absolute nut and they're trying to to
distance themselves from that nuttiness
but it's just not possible because we've
got the photographs we've got the
evidence we keep talking about it Earth
Day was crazy then it remains crazy
today it's a bizarre pantheistic back
and i'll whose predictions have
basically none of them have come true
and that's why people are ignoring it 50
years later and probably we should we
should continue to ignore it as well but
don't forget the history because it's
pretty weird and creepy all right that's
our show I'm Michael Knowles is the
Michael Nolt show see tomorrow
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Ben Davies and directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy borin
supervising producers Mathis Glover and
Robert Stirling technical producer
Austin Stephens assistant director pavel
madoski editor and associate producer
danny D'Amico audio mixer robin fenders
hair and makeup nikka geneva production
assistant ryan love the michael knowles
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 20
you know the Matt Walsh oh it's not just
another show about about politics I
think there are enough of those already
out there we talk about culture because
culture drives politics and it drives
everything else so my main focus is our
life family faith those are fundamental
and that's what this show is about I
hope you'll give it a listen
you